few investors over the past couple of
years have celebrated bitcoin's rise
like Anthony pompliano better known as
pomp from frequent appearances on this
Ferry Network to a popular podcast he's
been spreading the gospel far and wide
he is with us now as you can see for his
first TV interview since the FTX story
broke welcome it's good to have you in
overtime Anthony
thanks so much for having me yeah what
is your reaction to what happened with
FTX
yeah listen I think there's one major
theme uh everyone is shocked and uh
they're shocked because most of the
narrative over the last couple of years
has been uh major players are shunning
regulation they don't want to engage in
the United States they want to run and
hide in other jurisdictions and I think
part of why this is so shocking is this
was a player that Not only was regulated
in some regards some of their entities
but also was engaging in Washington and
with regulators and so I think that that
just led to a bigger and bigger surprise
one other thing that I want to call out
also is uh there's an individual Ian
Allison at coindesk who actually broke
part of this story uh with one of the
balance sheets and I think that uh it's
important that this wasn't the
mainstream media this wasn't some of the
critics this was actually somebody
within the crypto ecosystem who works at
a crypto Media company uh who did this
and so I think that's another
interesting point as well
what was your relationship if any with
FTX did you have money with them
um we had a business that had uh some
money with them we have a number of
funds and and uh different entities that
uh were either investors LPS uh that had
money on the platforms uh I've got a
business where uh they had an
advertising relationship with FTX us
um and so you know this was a major play
the second largest crypto exchange uh in
the world and to see this happen I think
again it's just pretty shocking yeah
what's the status of whatever you know
money you had with them the advertising
relationship you had do you do you have
any idea or what the status of it is now
most people are all sitting there saying
what's going on right uh and that's
unfortunate uh because there's so many
great things that are happening in this
industry and then we can touch on some
of those uh advancements but I think
right now everyone uh is kind of
operating with the same amount of
information which is what they're
reading on Twitter
um and uh that that's unfortunate
there's a lot of people who are upset
who are mad uh who frankly don't know
what to do
um and hopefully that that gets cleared
up quickly we can get some more
information but right now I think
there's just a lot of people who are
saying I don't have any information I
don't know what's going on I mean you're
pretty well connected in the crypto
world have you spoken with Sam
backmanfried
I've not spoken with Sam uh I don't
think many people have spoken with Sam
uh I think that Sam uh uh you know is
obviously dealing with a lot of stuff
right now
um and frankly the conversations in
private of many people in this industry
are saying uh I think three things one
this is shocking two uh they are very
surprised at how well some of the assets
are holding up given the second largest
crypto Exchange in the world uh just
imploded and had a file for bankruptcy
uh and then the third thing is there's a
lot of people wondering what's next
right does this chill institutional
interest how will this actually affect
uh retail interest what is going to
happen to some of the technologies that
people were very excited about what will
the results be for other infrastructure
players both the regulated and
unregulated players there's a lot of
open questions that I think are
important to talk through
um but but ultimately I think that the
industry uh is coming together and
saying to themselves like hey this is a
big moment uh it's a negative moment but
ultimately they still have deep
conviction uh that Bitcoin is going to
end end up continuing to thrive in the
future
you tweeted last night I'm going to
quote from it I know many of you are mad
upset hurt and confused I am sorry
unfortunately I don't have more
information on what to do I I have
Bitcoin locked on platforms as well this
sucks there's no hiding that you say I'm
I am sorry what are you sorry for
yeah I think that every single person in
this industry right now is sorry that
anyone is suffering right part of the
beauty of uh Bitcoin specifically is
that Bitcoin is going to usher in a
better future that's the promise of the
technology it is going to restore the
ability to maintain your purchasing
power over long periods of times is
going to bring economic empowerment to
billions of people around the world now
of course as we have seen many times in
this industry there are ups and downs
there are things that people try right
in many cases in the past the implosions
or the failures that we've seen have
just been people experimenting where it
didn't work this seems to be something
else I think we'll get more information
on that over time I I don't know if we
can call that yet but obviously that
would be an important detail and so
sorry is just in general when you see
people suffering uh you don't want to
see that these are many people that I
know very well people who have worked
hard who have tried to build that future
that they want to see and you know
already I think people were having a lot
of pain or experience a lot of pain if
you look across the last year bitcoin's
down 75 percent now there's a lot of
stocks that are down significantly as
well Facebook's down 65 percent uh
Nvidia Amazon they're down 45 right so
just the Federal Reserve has said
they're going to destroy demand they've
done an excellent job of destroying
investment demand uh and it looks like
they're starting to get inflation under
control to some degree as well but to
have an entire year where it's basically
been down only for asset prices across
markets to then have this kind of big
moment uh it just hurts right people
want to go back to having the good times
they want to see that future ushered in
and ultimately I think that uh we need
to have these moments because it does
create resilience
um but but it still sucks when you go
through it but I mean some and I'm
wondering what you make of the the fact
that some are pointing fingers at people
like you and other so-called evangelists
who have been as I said at the outset on
this network from the beginning on your
own podcast and in other media forums
pushing Bitcoin relentlessly
um as a store of value as as the kind of
asset that seems to be far from maybe
what it actually was at least at this
particular time how would you respond to
that sort of criticism
well you guys have had uh Warren Buffett
and Charlie Munger and paraded him
around the network uh as these great
investors which they absolutely are
they're some of the best investors that
have lived during our lifetime but if
you go back to the beginning of the
pandemic when bitcoiners were calling
out saying the undisciplined monetary
and fiscal policy was going to be debase
the dollar inflation would not be
transitory and Bitcoin would be an asset
that you would want to fly to uh to look
for safety if you go and you look
Bitcoin has outperformed Berkshire
Hathaway it's outperformed the most
assets right it's up almost a hundred
percent during this period of absolute
insane undisciplined monetary and fiscal
policy and so yes it is down 75 over the
last year but bitcoiners also continued
to just Hammer the same point over and
over and over again dollar cost average
long-term hold into a finite asset where
demand will increase because the
debasement of currencies and what we
have seen as that continues to play out
and so what I always tell people is
don't listen to what I'm saying just
simply watch what I'm doing and I've
been buying multiple times this year as
the price has been falling I continue to
dollar cost average I continue to have
very high conviction in this asset and
just as I used to come on this show in
2018 and say I believe that Bitcoin over
a long period of time will outperform a
lot of other assets I still believe that
today and I'm putting my money where my
mouth is and time will tell you I know
you are you you are but isn't it
dangerous to to suggest that others put
money where your mouth is given what's
happened to go from you know 60 plus
thousand to to where we are today and
and you mentioned Munger and Buffett by
the way Munger who has called crypto rat
poison in the past said just this
morning that crypto is quote Rife with
fraud and delusion of crypto itself he
said quote the country did not need a
currency that was good for kidnappers
Carl Icahn the other day told me it's
Lawless like the wild west those guys
were pilloried especially monger and
Buffett by people like you when they
made those initial statements doesn't
this bear out that they're right
no I think there's two things here first
is if we're going to talk about Just
Pure Performance Shopify and doordash
are down 75 to 90 percent right these
they're stocks literally just tech
stocks that are openly talked about on
financial networks that are down more
than Bitcoin so if Bitcoin is so great
are we now going to argue that Shopify
is uh not valuable that it's over no of
course not so I think that that's just
an argument that doesn't really have any
legs in terms of Charlie Munger as I've
said over and over and over again they
do not understand the technology to
confuse Bitcoin and crypto one is a
false comparison the second thing is
that the US dollar is used more for
money laundering or criminal activity
than Bitcoin the former CIA director
came out with a study to show that right
and so as you go through the arguments I
get it right people want to have the
headline grabbing a kind of anti-bitcoin
statements they want to have the
critiques but as you continue to look at
the technology this is a decentralized
peer-to-peer Network that has a great
track record of protecting purchasing
power over long periods of time and
bitcoiners are trying to Usher back in
Timeless investing principles Warren
Buffett and Charlie Munger buy great
assets hold them forever that is a
Bitcoin principle dollar cost average
into great assets that is a Bitcoin
principle and so I believe that if
Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger were
25 to 35 years old today they'd be
bitcoiners the difference though is they
didn't have the opportunity to allow for
decentralized software-based money to
come along to store their assets Bitcoin
has outperformed their Investments over
the last decade and it has continued to
during this period of undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy and I believe
that they will continue to hate on
bitcoin they will continue to say things
that show they don't understand it the
pro the problem is is if you want to do
and you make the analogy to various
stocks you can do a fundamental analysis
on a company's projected earning power
over a set period of years decide what
the correct valuation is to pay for that
future growth you can't do any of that
in crypto you can't do any of that with
Bitcoin you can be a believer in
blockchain technology and still think
that crypto is a highly speculative
asset based on next to nothing
well again I don't believe that to be
true right so I would say two things one
is you can definitely do a fundamental
analysis take hash rate as an example
Bitcoin is the most secure Computing
Network in the world hash rates at an
all-time high price is down 75 and hash
rate keeps climbing there's a
dislocation between price and
fundamentals 67 of the Bitcoin that is
in circulation right now today has not
moved in 12 months the price of Bitcoin
fell 75 and 67 of the Bitcoin didn't
move we are watching the greatest battle
of 2022 where it is bitcoiners and the
hodlers versus the macro environment and
I'm willing to bet and I am betting that
the bitcoiners will Outlast the macro
tightening Financial conditions and
ultimately the Federal Reserve and other
central banks around the world will have
to return to loose monetary and fiscal
policy and what we will see is that the
hodlers will still be huddling they will
still be bitcoining and ultimately the
people who do not understand the
technology we'll continue to hate on it
but Bitcoin doesn't care it produces
block after block after block of
transactions and it is the only monetary
policy in the world over the last three
years that did not change we have a
report
I I reference and forgive me for
interrupting you but there's a report
and I reference this at the top of the
the uh the segment here about another
crypto related uh entity that may be in
trouble Wall Street Journal uh reporting
that blockfi is preparing for a
potential bankruptcy I watched a clip
before we did this interview in which
you called it a quote rocket ship get on
board you said I am bullish bullish
bullish I mean isn't that part of the
problem don't you have any regrets
whatsoever for making statements like
that and perhaps putting people who are
less experienced than you into some of
these assets
yeah I mean Scott you can take anything
out of context I've literally recorded
1200 podcast episodes right you can go
back and find all kinds of crazy stuff
but the context you're talking about was
I was an investor in the company in a
private placement round where accredited
investors evaluated a business and put
capital in if something happens to a
company that I'm an investor in then we
lose money that is called capitalism
it's called taking risk and the fact
that we now want to take that and
somehow spin it or pull it out of
context I think is inappropriate instead
what I think we should be talking about
is the fact that we have businesses in
the United States who now are suffering
at the hands of what appears to be a
potential fraud again we will get those
details but now as those businesses are
suffering we have funds we have
different uh centralized infrastructure
companies this all happened in the
United States which supposedly we were
yelling and screaming about people who
are running around trying to avoid
regulation we need to get our act
together in the United States because
this technology is not going away
it
this is not about pointing fingers this
is this is not about that I think it's
it's mostly about uh understanding the
power that you have with as many Twitter
followers as you have with the
captivating voice and our articulate way
that you describe this asset
um in an environment that that grew to
be highly speculative you don't think
that that you have the power to
influence people to get into certain
areas of the market that maybe they
shouldn't be in you don't think that's a
fair question to ask
you can ask whatever questions you want
Scott CNBC is the most powerful
Financial Network in the world and
people critique CNBC for pumping Bitcoin
I don't see anyone on CNBC apologizing
for that you talk about an asset just
because somebody criticizes you for
something doesn't mean they're right and
so if you're going to argue that CNBC is
not as powerful as me with a single
Twitter account that's insane and so
ultimately there's no difference between
any of the media platforms right I have
a media platform it happens to be under
my name you have a media platform
there's plenty of people you've been
talking about Bitcoin all day at the end
of the day people will critique the
assets but the bitcoiner Mantra dollar
cost average hold a great asset forever
those are Timeless investing principles
that Warren Buffett Charlie Munger and
many other investors go ahead and look
at and just because the price goes down
again there are other companies and
stocks and assets that go up and down in
price this is how markets work and so no
I don't think that CNBC should be
criticized for talking about an ass said
you have people who come on who like it
you have people who come on that don't
like it I have people who talk about it
positively I have people who talk about
it negatively that is where the
conversation lies and rather than simply
going around and trying to yell and
scream at each other in the bad times
what I think we should do is we should
encourage more conversation we should
have conversations like this where
people who like the asset who don't like
the asset come together they discuss it
and then ultimately the free market will
decide what happens I have a view I'm
expressing that in the market and we'll
see what happens okay it is undeniable
that confidence in this asset class has
taken a tremendous hit
um
don't don't listen to anything anyone
says 67 of Bitcoin in circulation has
not moved it's an all-time high it's
never been higher bitcoiners are holding
they are not selling this asset that's
what the mainstream media does not
understand bitcoiners do not care about
the price and you can see it in the data
it's all on chain anyone in the world
can evaluate it 67 bought it higher and
they're not selling it so they're
holding on in your words for dear life
because they're they're Believers still
they don't want to believe that the
investment is is not coming back I mean
that's not true either because wallet
addresses on chain with 0.1 and 0.01
Bitcoin this is literally hundreds to a
couple thousand dollars the number of
wallet addresses on chain continues to
hit all-time highs the people not
institutions not nation states the
people continue to buy Bitcoin it is
available for anyone in the world to
audit on-chain data that is the beauty
of Bitcoin this is not for up for
opinion it's not up for debate there is
hard data that you can go on you can
look at yourself 67 of Bitcoin is not
being sold and the number of Wallets on
chain that continue to dollar cost
average into this asset is going up it's
hitting all-time highs you don't think
that you don't think that institutions
are going to more closely scrutinize the
the Investments that they make in this
space after the FTX blow up you really
don't believe that you don't you don't
think the average investor is going to
sit at home and think maybe crypto isn't
what I thought it was I'm afraid of
losing all my money despite what Anthony
pompliano suggests I might want to do
well Scott see you're conflating two
things you're conflating the centralized
Equity Investments with Bitcoin which is
a decentralized currency no I'm talking
about the confidence in the space itself
I'm talking about the confidence which
has clearly taking a hit how couldn't it
when when uh an individual like Sam
bankman freed has his fortune literally
blow up overnight when one of the
largest crypto exchanges in the world
blows up overnight and fortunes are lost
small fortunes by people who can't
afford to lose it are lost
you don't think that there's going to be
more scrutiny on the kinds of
Investments that are made both by
individuals and institutions in the
future and you don't think it's relevant
to discuss what restores that confidence
in what is still a fledgling asset class
with next to no regulations whatsoever
well I I never said that there wasn't
going to be more scrutiny I absolutely
believe that I've tweeted that publicly
the second thing is it is regulated you
have to stop saying that this industry
is regulated in the United States if you
run a centralized exchange you have to
go get approvals from Regulators The
Regulators are doing the best job that
they possibly can to continue to have
oversight here saying is unregulated in
the United States is just false that is
inaccurate information there are places
in the world where it is not as
regulated as in the United States the
actors in the United States of America
want to do three things they want to
build great companies that solve
problems for customers they want to be
regulated in a way where they feel like
they can operate their business and also
adhere to whatever rules The Regulators
believe are accurate and the third thing
that they want to do is that they want
to create economic opportunities that is
what capitalism is about that is what
this country was built on it is what the
American dream is all about and if
there's obviously not regulated enough
even the biggest players in the business
suggest that it needs more regulation
Bernie Madoff was regulated of course if
bad people are going to do bad things
duh of course but the regulations only
work and people are telling the truth if
the Auditors go in and they audit and in
this case there's accusations that
somebody created a back door to change
the numbers so the Auditors couldn't
tell ultimately bad people do bad things
but that doesn't mean it's not regulated
right that's not what that means and the
big players aren't saying bring on more
regulation what they're saying instead
is hey we understand where the rules are
we need to get this right in the United
States of America we cannot create rules
that push people outside the U.S we have
to do this here in the US the US has the
best Capital market system in the world
and it is The Shining Light On The Hill
if we want to continue to do that
especially in this industry we have to
have rules that make sense we have to do
it so that people can actually operate
their businesses within it and what you
will find is there is great appetite in
The Operators and entrepreneurs to work
with Regulators to create that
environment and I think actually
regulators and the entrepreneurs want
that together they're working as hard as
they can on it but to say that there is
not regulation in the United States it's
just flat out false
we're going to leave it there Anthony I
appreciate your time